the entire internet is going crazy over
at nepo babies yeah you heard that right
nepo short for nepotism referring to the
kids of celebrities who landed their own
careers in the same industry of their
parents New York Magazine dubbing 2022
as the year of the nepo baby saying she
has her mother's eyes and agent ooh
slaying but the nepo babies aren't happy
about it Kate Hudson daughter of Goldie
Hawn says it's not fair for
entertainment to be singled out I see it
in business way more than I see it in
Hollywood sometimes I've been in
business meetings where I'm like whose
child is this like this person knows
nothing and Jamie Lee Curtis daughter of
Tony Curtis and Janet Lee calls herself
oh gee nippo baby but says the
discussion is trying to diminish her
work I guess my first question is who
has children in a business meeting but I
guess I didn't did I read that wrong she
means like the CEO of the company is
that is like basically has to be
somebody's child because they're not
thank you thank you for clearing up
listen nepotism is a real thing but and
and when we see it in all forms we see
it all the time and we see bad versions
of nepotism is it fair
maybe not for those of us who had to
come from nothing to get where we are
yet you can see it but here's the deal I
do have to say even though you if your
parents success put you in the position
it's up to you to make it because you
know a perfect example we see that with
I don't want to say it because Will
Smith's having a bad year but Will
Smith's son's acting career didn't
really take off like he thought it was
going to so we see examples of bad
nepotism where are you on this okay
thank you very much no um I think that
obviously you have a benefit if one of
your parents is a big star in Hollywood
they know the best people they know
which casting agencies to go to they
could get you a small role in a film
that they're doing however like you said
being put in that role is different than
succeeding and I think a lot of these
people who have famous parents you know
Angelina Jolie Miley Cyrus I think
they're actually a lot more successful
and talented than their parents were and
so I think there's something to be said
about parents making it and then passing
down the fruits of their labor to their
children whether it's in a family
business or whether it's in Hollywood
and I would also say that a lot of the
time the kids of these very famous
people do not turn out well at all and
so if you can make you know be
successful and talented in the industry
and the parents can you know bring you
along to have a successful career I
don't really think there's anything
wrong with that as long as you can prove
yourself as well and make your own way
eventually once you get that that hand
up yeah because I mean Jamie Lee Curtis
is an institution and a franchise I
think she's far as Western father in
terms of what she's done I mean
Halloween and then at one time she was
like every every poster she was on every
poster a very young man in America who
was like wow she was it so you have a
little bit of celebrity and Nine and
Nine children yeah are you gonna use
NEPA or is it going to be because with
me it's like Case by case like if I I
they have to do the work to get the
auditions are you the same mindset I I
think it's natural I think it's human to
want to help your children and I think
as you said whether you have a
construction business or a restaurant we
all want to help our kids be in that
business Kate Hudson actually said you
know we come from we're a family of
storytellers it's kind of in US I mean
there is something about the Arts on the
other hand in the 1950s 16 of people
came of our people in the Arts came from
the working class it's obvious the Arts
have always been for people from the
upper classes it's a Leisure you have to
have that kind of support system you
know to get out now it's only seven
percent so in defense of those who are
trolling all these nepo babies I will
say the only only thing I agree with
them is that we don't want all of our
stories you know in terms of movies and
TV shows to come from the perspective of
the elite and the privilege we do want
those working-class stories to come out
because that is the true America that
said everyone should want to help their
kids that's what we're that's why we
have them
you know there's that famous rest I can
give it to you but what you're going to
do with it and that's kind of how it I
don't think these are examples are good
examples of nepotism because they've all
been successful would you agree I tend
to agree with that listen I think
nepotism exists everywhere I think most
when you even when you go to the
doctor's office and you ask your doctors
like oh my dad or my mom was a doctor I
mean I think it's something that you see
in every industry and I think when you
see it in Hollywood it's oftentimes you
the folks that we're talking about are
folks who they're parents they've also
either their parents are such women
they're also successful the name that
comes to mind for me is Diana Ross and
her daughter Tracy Ellis Ross who I
would say at this point in time they're
sort of equal in their celebrity right
Diana Ross is successful and her
daughter's accessible so I think
nepotism to Rachel's point is something
where Mom and Dad did it and mom and dad
decides to help child and child does it
and child successful
so goes it
well okay with your success and you're a
celebrity now would you because I don't
necessarily want my kids in
entertainment I don't necessarily want
my kids to wrestle I would like them to
have a different path in mind where are
you on that yeah it's number one public
figure maybe that celebrity's a heavy
word but um you can look at your arms
you can carry it we'll take it we'll
take it listen real quick uh Kiefer
Sutherland Donald Sullivan there's a lot
of examples in Hollywood specifically of
extremely talented people but I'll give
you one that hits closer to home I
started learning how to do this job
Politics on TV at 27 years old after two
wars in the college education Peter
Ducey started learning to do this job at
probably three years old and he's one of
the best ones doing it there's a
difference between putting somebody in a
place and training them throughout their
life to go get it and I think that's
nepotism has a lot of different meanings
and it's definitely not all bad no yeah
so Tyrus I have a question for you on
that so how about if your kid want to be
a producer would you allow that to
happen if they well I have no control
over that because I can't get they
wanted but if they did yeah go do it as
long as they did the work yeah I would I
would help them I would support them as
long as I thought they were good at it
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else